what is up what is good homies how you
livin you see the set which means I'm an
Atlanta but we're not talking to a
former football player we're talking to
the icon a living legend the man the
myth himself
Ernie frickin Johnson and he's shaking
his head as the comments wash over him I
had no idea my middle initial was F yeah
I had milk in the party thanks man
you look amazing if it's free it's me
you got the you got the threes on yes
indeed man if they're free they're for
me
I got mice do you like my sweater game
by the way you can be honest you know
you know what have you watched the show
it doesn't a good start have you watched
the show at IKEA like I probably can't
say it because it's it's the S word oh
but it's spelled as ch itds
Greek I have not seen it it's the guy
he's reminiscent of the of that guy's
sweater game but this is okay thanks if
there's some monkeys on it it's not as
it's not as off-the-wall as the guy in s
crease well look you have Botox actually
it was actually Eugene Levy son
reactional real life and plays his son
in this in this thing you need to watch
the show
I will check an ass hilarious you have
bow ties I have sweaters
when did bowties start mmm who's your
bonus five I think it was like five
years ago hmm I'm thinking and I mean
because life goes by a lot faster now
for me you know when you get a little
older the years kind of click by yeah I
think you know I'll say five years and
somebody will actually say no it was
actually nine years ago but I think it
was like five years ago and I was my
wife and I Cheryl Ann and I were hosting
our annual Christmas party and I said
I'm gonna wear a bow tie this year I
have no idea how to tie a bow tie gotta
wear a bow tie or anything so I got a
bow tie and a head like reindeer on it
or something or or some kind of a car
with a Christmas tree on top and and so
I wore it and I was like that was kind
of fun to wear that you know they got a
ton of
compliments ya at the party Barry oh
yeah bowtie I went to the I went to the
mall
the next a couple of days later and
picked up like three bowties no never
hooked I said I'm gonna try wearing one
on the air and I know and I wore it and
people killed me you know Ernie you got
that bowtie there's also you know you
got the faceless masses on Twitter oh
yeah you know and so they cranked out
all the Orville Redenbacher and all that
I mean so really if you can survive the
first month of wearing a bow tie your
thing now then it became isn't it was
like I appear somewhere like doing a
baseball game at a regular tie or doing
golf and a regular point a what's up
with it where's the bow wow so yeah it's
become kind of it's it's a hoop thing
for me it's March Madness and it's it's
NBA random questions just to start this
off that wasn't random
yeah well that was one of my randoms
favorite player to watch favorite player
to right now favorite basketball player
player to watch
favorite basketball player to watch she
watches all the K sub is russell
westbrook mmm just for the energy
perspective the energy and and you never
doubt that on a game night well as
russell was were gonna show up right he
always shows up that's what happens when
you have to watch all 82 you see the
guys that don't show because i mean it
goes back and forth I mean I love
watching staff too because I love
watching good shooters and I think we
all relate to shooters more than we
relate to dunkers you know because we
can yeah we can't dunk you know but we
can all go on the back yard and shoot
and so that's why I think like the
three-point contest at all-star weekend
always resonates with people a little
more I mean you want to see the dunk
yeah but you associate more with it who
is a host on TV that you marvel at their
ability because I do TV was no stop it
was and I think well for me Brent
Musburger early on and then really it
was Bob Costas and it was and it was
Costas because it that we were doing the
NBA at the same time it was
kind of early in my careers in the 90s
in my career and Bob obviously was
established and and I used to watch and
I and look I have no problem saying it I
would watch this guy like a hawk and say
how does he how does he do this
how does he maintain how does he work
humor in how does he react when
something's not right of when they roll
the wrong tape and I and and so I
learned a lot from him and and and I you
know it's it's just like one of those
things where the longer you stay in it
the more you realize things are gonna
happen yes and if you just play him off
it's great and perfection isn't real
rather than acting like oh no that was
the wrong graphic or it was the wrong
tape or yes or the teleprompter broke so
it was really those two guys but really
way back it was Johnny Carson
I watched Johnny Carson as a kid and
coolest dude ever unquestioned they come
to him and they be wowed by him yeah
yeah it was just like you know he was
hilarious but he was even funnier when
things weren't funny you know when our
joke bombed and he just look at the rock
playing you know yeah yeah he was
tremendous so those are like those are
like three that I've you know I have
much admiration for everybody for sure
we do not I mean you look across all the
platforms all the networks everywhere
and you see such talented people doing
it and man I'm just you know I'm sitting
here on thirty years yeah you know it
inside the NBA and haven't had to work a
day in my life I think what's really
cool about this place and you feel it on
a game night back there the energy is
really great it doesn't feel like a
television studio it feels like a family
hanging out watching basketball and now
we're gonna go talk about it but you
were saying earlier that you watch Bob
now people walk in and they do what I do
and they shower you with compliments and
you go okay enough there but there had
to be a time where you were like why
aren't more people talking about us
probably early on cuz well probably
because I was doing the show by myself
so there was good reason not to talk
about you know it was me by myself or
than
early on it was me with Reggie Theus me
with Cheryl Miller dick force ace you
know and so yeah the show was great it
was fun to do but it wasn't making way
no you know you know when Kenny came
aboard we started getting a little bit
of that vibe and then when Chuck came on
it changed Alliance and that's when it
changed oh yeah I mean that changed it
big time for all of it was it show one
or was there like a moment that happened
like now you can trend on Twitter but
I'm just curious like how did you feel
that impact back then I think that I
think there was just great anticipation
because you know it was like a free
agent summer with NBA players is their
worst Kevin Durant gonna go it was that
feel back at the the turn of the century
hmm when Charles was retired and it was
where's Charles gonna light is it going
to be NBC hey Peyton Manning yeah I mean
yeah and and so and we kind of all
thought he's gonna go to NBC you know
and and and then it was like one of
these things where he just said it just
looks like they have more fun over there
Turner and lucky face the truth I wasn't
yeah yeah well I mean that's kind of
what we were you know I think that's
probably what we kind of put out there
when Kenny and I were doing the show is
that this is a fun time yeah and but you
know my only concern when he joined it
was is when the novelty wears off is he
going to say you know okay this was fun
for a year or two now what can we do
yeah I never expected that like 19 years
later he'd still you know he as he walks
in the studio every every night we're on
is it let's have some fun tonight y'all
and that and we always do yeah yeah he
changed I mean he changed it for us he
changed it for TV
Charles changed the landscape he made it
okay to to go outside the lines a little
bit and speak your truth I think the
truth and not just have to talk about
the game ya know if there was something
going on in the world that everybody
else in the world was talking right it
was okay for us to talk about it too I
know that you and Tim Kiley do so much
you guys have been together for how long
um over 20 years and he's I don't know
his official executive producer Evans
yeah you know
he was the he was the line producer for
you know doing every show for ya a long
time
Jeremy Levin you know he's kind of
handed that baton right but but TK is
still like the overseeing and walking
around and yeah the unbuttoned of he'll
tell ya he'll tell Jeremy you know like
hey you know you might want to have this
you know piece of video because you
might want to hit right so and so yeah
he still oversees the thing and he's the
best guy I've ever had in my ear I mean
you know yes work smear that's that's
your guy it's the life line yeah you
know and so it's you to then you added
Kenny and then Chuck and I'm I'm more
curious for you guys it takes an absence
of ego and an awareness to be the two
that build the show and then allow the
show to get destroyed on purpose and I'm
curious like how did that conversation
go in the beginning like did you guys
realize that right away what else came
on you guys you guys have your meeting
and you go this is what we need to do
and you keep Charles and Kenny and Shaq
out of it and I think it's it's a
testament to your guys self-awareness to
go it's not about us no no no I mean
look we we just want to know what's in
the saddlebags that night as we go on
this ride no and and so we know we got
this video you know I have this story
you know I got this this research with
these quotes and yeah wait where's it
gonna work and and then if it all
vaporizes that's fine because it means
it's been replaced by something
organically that's really good it's
funny though that no other show does
that no I mean it is kind it's the magic
yeah and I think it is because we you
can you can look at a lot of the things
that people talk about the day after
about oh did you see this on inside and
a lot of times it wasn't anything that
we discussed in a production meeting it
was something that just happened and
there was and there's no way I mean
there's no way you could ever sit in a
production meeting and say well look
after the you know it in post came
tonight after Shaq admits that he
doesn't know where the Golden State
Warriors play their games will you know
that just happens and then
you know we absolutely torture him for
the next three segments and then into
the next night and so know the best kind
of humor is the stuff that you don't
plan it just happens because if you try
to do too much and say okay let's do
this this will be a real funny bit and
sometimes we do that we say look here's
what we want to do for the neato stud of
the night I don't know exactly how it's
gonna turn out but here's the the basic
concept yes and and invariably it turns
out better than anything that anybody
would have drawn out and said you say
this you say this you say this I mean
just to give people behind the curtain
because I like to do this with media on
the show it's you guys had a sponsored
segment with T so where you get a time
limit to get through yeah which if you
do sponsors on most shows you're okay we
have to allocate this amount of time but
that led to the shack going it's
supposed to be 1 2 3 not 1 2 1 but here
and that was so beautiful the thing
that's ridiculous about that we've done
that segment yes many many times and you
know we put a time on the clock but it's
not like we have to be done with the
discussion yes you know it's not a
hard-and-fast it's just like hey let's
go for three minutes and if it goes for
five or six okay you know if it's good
and for some reason that night shacks
looking at the clock say in 30 seconds
and then he's like you disrespected me
you know and yeah and and again here are
the variables that make that moment
funny
number one it's two o'clock in the
morning when this is half that's the
thing and things get things get seemed
funny or at two o'clock don't worry for
some reason and the previous week shack
had you know had this very profound
statement at halftime
after somebody had maybe it was Lillard
or somebody had a huge first half and
and Shaq came out and said now remember
three things can happen in the second
half you could have more points fewer
points or the same number a boy yeah and
we were like wow no kiddin of course
what are you talking about that's true I
said I know but that those are the only
three things
that can happen it has to be there's
only news if you had a fourth that none
of us have thought that's the exactly so
we all laugh about that and then within
a week here he comes out with how you're
supposed to go 1 2 2 2 3 and you want
one to two back to one you lost it I did
so silly because Kenny's laughing about
one thing yes yeah Shaq is threatening
to to King Charles but yeah and I'm
sitting there in the middle saying what
is going on here and wait where did this
one to two to three
you realize I'm just realizing this now
what you said about the three-point
contest is the reason why everybody like
resonates with you I think during the
show because if any of us were in that
seat we would feel as hopeless as you
felt like with it's going back and forth
I will sometimes watch and go how is
earning gonna get to break right now
like how do you like these are three
Bulls in a china shop and you're sitting
there and there's probably Sona you're
going
we're Ted over we're 20 over well yeah
the lot they were not wedded to the
stopwatch like Judy and Jeremy aren't
aren't tied to that with we got to get
off because we're a little bit of an
open-ended show it at some point but we
don't want something to run after it's
been after it's funny okay let's keep on
doing this so and I realize sometimes in
the course of that especially in a
playoff night they've got some buddies
at the podium that they want to yeah we
want to go hear from Jamal Murray here
and meantime I'm getting you went
instead of going 1 2 2 2 3 1 1 2 2 2
back go on and it's and then I'm here
and hey we got to Steve cursed and it's
like what are you doing and what are you
saying and what are you laughing about
and why are we talking about Felipe
Lopez no I mean it was like it's just
this maelstrom of stuff that's going on
you know Dorothy you know it's a twister
you know and and and then finest later
but I see on Twitter someone say I don't
know why it's just the best show on tea
you know that's how it's well said I
don't know why either and and I would
never call us the best show on TV but I
I mean look I know sports fans have
enjoyed it
they they and I they love the
spontaneity they love the
unpredictability and I think you know
the point you make is they're sitting
out there watching the show wondering
what's gonna happen next I am too
yeah so we're all in that same boat your
book is awesome unscripted you're very
good I was I listened to the audiobook
my lips I did Wow
so I'm just gonna say love you - love
you a lot
but what what with what you're saying
there I'm always interested in a
breakdown of inventory of your of your
work day so you have we're shooting that
son of Monday he's gonna come out next
week you have two games tonight yeah
what people don't realize is you guys
are here until 2:00 in the morning on a
doubleheader like that you get here at
what time I try to get in seven hours
before the [ __ ] game says we're the
first game for the first game so if
we're on at seven I try to be in by noon
and you do the math we're on at eight I
try to get him by one thanks man but
it's all you know and that's all just a
function of routine and it's like a game
day thing it's your routine is
phenomenal no but it's a you get here at
noon yeah and then what's the breakdown
after that I grab some lunch oh you know
I usually go up here to the to the
cafeteria first they got a great place
beautiful it's off it's awesome
so I'll grab me a salad I'll grab me a
salad where did that come from
grab me a salad I grab a salad and
that's the Georgia Hall of Famer yeah
there you go and so let me get some of
that lettuce yeah take some of the grain
some of the Yeller
so anyway I I come down there and then I
get on my computer and I print out
something from Elias which is the latest
stats yes and from last night's games
that and something that doesn't come
down to like three o'clock in the
morning and then you update your files
but no then I go through the articles
sports scan thing that lists every team
and there you know there's articles from
all their writers about what's going on
so well nor are games and say see some
quotes from somebody
you know pull off a bunch of those and
then start updating all the notes that I
keep and then talk to our producer and
say hey what do you you know what are
you thinking about yeah
what are we you know what are we doing
tonight and then I kind of go in the
bunker for a few hours and just finalize
all my stuff and your stand then go to
then go to and then go to a production
meeting after that colour-coded
organized yeah
what is how many shoes would you say you
bring up on set with you there's a
there's like a little pamphlet that I
create for each game it's you had to
bring one page that it would be the top
page it has the each team's profile it
has the stats that I've updated through
you know like what their guy's numbers
are for that series and my post season
overall and there's a no one on the
regular season so I got a little like
like like I'm a team note it's Milwaukee
I'd have an 18 for what they for what
they averaged in the regular season but
writing 22 for what they averaged in the
first series and then what they're
averaging against Boston and then what
they're ravaging for the post and so
they're like eight categories that I
list down one margin and then I do the
players the same way yeah and then if
there's a good quote or somebody said
something you got that right center
that's in there too so it was not like
it all goes right in here oh then once
but once I see it and I write it down I
know where I put it so I can get my
hands on it so if somebody says
something about well Denver really needs
to do this and I said well my cologne
says you know so yeah I'm just trying to
like trying to kind of generate
conversation and I'm trying to clarify
things if you know if one of our guys
says something like well that there are
terrible defensive team well I would say
that well there's no they're they're
number two and defensive efficiency well
I don't care about defensive efficiency
because I don't care about you know says
you know all that so but that's my job I
can't just say guys you talk and I'm not
gonna try to fact-check you on anything
well you're the backbone because well
know what I realized is when I saw your
statistics you are the weather vane or
you you're your absolute zero where if
anything goes to absolute zero yeah if
anything goes too far one way you can
always bring it back and I'm always
amazed like I
a lot of young people will always hit me
up and they'll talk about winging it it
just seems so natural I only think
that's possible if your preparation is
is there yeah because we wing it I mean
we you know our conversation is when
guys are gonna sit down thirty Seconds
to a minute before we go on the air for
a pregame show or for a halftime show or
a postgame show you know they're not
expecting that we're gonna say hey let's
run through segment three real quick I'm
gonna say this you say this and you say
this it's like we want gut level
reactions yeah so like as we came on the
air last night you know we're talking
about Portland and Denver and they saw I
can't wait to show Shaq this enes kanter
tweet where he's complaining about yo
kitsch
yeah and I'm the business on the on the
left shoulder because I know the Shaq's
not gonna come in having said hey have
you guys seen this and a scanner thing I
said this'll be great good and so he's
like man I love that I love them you
know and then Charles at the same time
it's like well I don't think that's
uncalled for I said well that's what
Terry Stotts says it's uncalled for and
then it just generates this whole
conversation I was gonna say you have to
be at a point now where whether it's a
clip or a tweet I bet you could predict
all of their reactions you know before
it even happened it's crazy that you say
that because it is it does get to that
point and it's gotten to the point where
there there are times you know what I'll
voice a tease for the night's game
source and our CSS you guys are creative
folks do a wonderful job on those and so
they sell the game and it's you know you
know it's really slickly produced and
boom but sometimes there might be a line
in there that describes somebody as a
superstar for instance you know led by a
superstar at so-and-so you know and I'm
voicing this thing I said let's let's
back off on that and let's find another
word I said because when we come out of
the tease Chuck's gonna say oh so he's a
superstar now huh like I understand it's
my it and it's not my writing but it's
my voice and so it's got to be something
that I know look this is this is it's
got to be something that I believe like
I learned with Chuck from one day
that if I use the word expert it's a
trigger with him oh I say expert goes an
expert he no such thing as an expert
that's not bad but wait this like I had
this with with shows before where you
get to learn your analyst so well that I
actually need advice from you as you
could tell I have an interrupting
problem because what happens is
especially if I've worked with someone a
lot I know where their brains gonna go
and if it's a story they've already told
I want my audience to have fresh stuff I
don't want them to hear the same thing
so I interrupt and I don't know how to
not do that it's okay yeah it's it's
just like feel clear that feels like
being at home
but what were we talking about
so yeah just didn't know we were talking
knowing what your analyst I'm gonna say
before they even though you know because
when you've been around guys for 20
years you know that you know and if
you're if you're gonna go down a certain
Road yeah and it's and it's knowing too
that if I get Kenny to talk about this
that I know how Shaq's gonna react and
you know and I you know people talk
about Adam that you know this role and
it's you know is it a traffic cop is at
the point guard is that the is that the
guy at the circus with the with the
chair you know the whole hand tamer what
is the and the best one that somebody
told me was I'm the dad who's driving
cross-country with the kids in the
backseat turning around saying if I hear
one more peep out of you we are turning
this car around that's what it's like
and and on that and on the traffic cop
thing it's like I'm a really bad traffic
cop because I want to wave Kenny into
the intersection show that go go BAM and
then we're and then we're going yeah I
think you're more like the guy from the
is the progressive commercial the
progressive commercial that's he's like
trying to create havoc and mayhem yeah
you're you're inciting riots oh I'm not
trying to incite riots I just we
approach I'm trying to spark
conversation and debate on NBA topics
I'm just in terms
of we've already done bowtie favorite
watch favorite game of zones
representation you are such a fan of
this that when Thibodeau was in
backstage you lit up yeah because game
of zones they did a feature on him and
then Barkley came out and mention it and
then you said oh gee talk she talked to
Tom and Tom looked at you because what
were you too afraid it because because
yeah because I don't see Tibbs that much
and so he comes into to work NBATV yeah
and where you know hadn't it had been a
while but you know probably yeah we had
done a Minnesota game a couple years ago
on Christmas as a matter of fact and
that was the last time I seen Tibbs when
he was when he was coaching the
Timberwolves and so you know we're
catching up in hey how you doing and I
had just watched the night or two nights
before you know this whole Jimmy Butler
yeah the zones thing and and Tibbs is
like handing Andrew Wiggins back is hard
this can't be yours it's too large ya
know and and I guess I do like Robert
coming to his hustle a little bit you
know so and I'm thinking I wonder as I'm
talking to us I wonder if Tibbs has seen
that if he would ever look at it as I'm
gonna go there because because if it
struck a sore spot I don't want to say
it's you should see what they did the
odd game and so I'm just in the viewing
room with Chuck and I was like I said
you see Tibbs he said yeah yeah I said
man I was like I wondered if he had
though watch the game of zones but I cuz
Chuck loves it too yes oh I don't know
I'm gonna go out and ask him so no
Charles barrels out there's this dibs
you see that game of zones and it was
like man that was that was really funny
it was really really and I just wanted
to rub besides Chuck and he says yeah
Ernie said he was gonna ask you but he
didn't know if he was so you say oh he
said Charles out here to ask me I said
and that's not exactly how it Charles
volunteered to come out and ask but yeah
I did I did kind of whip out on it was
amazing because for me it was like
watching you guys turning it like
teenagers and you know you ask him know
us and then you're all just like saying
quotes from the episode the reason I
love it is like I'm good friends of the
mallet brothers I walk in their office
all the time and when you're making
creative like that and like art you have
no idea people's reactions you see
tweets you see YouTube and I came back
and told them that story and their faces
like lit up because for them to know
that Thibodeau watched it yeah blows
them away
no it's it their creativity is off the
charts it's one of those things like you
can't just watch the episode and then go
you've got to watch it and then you
watch it again because there's little
it's like when Alex who virus does are
going fishing there's little thing yes
in the background that you don't pick up
right and you and you have to watch it
and I always do it with the with the
closed caption on to so I can catch all
the dialogue and then there are
somewhere there's someone's like yelling
in the back something that you might not
catch you're like oh that's hilarious oh
no their whole deal on the raptors in
the trade of DeMar DeRozan with Kyle
Lowry and in Messiah jury being unable
to say Jakob Pirtle you know it happened
Jakob poet tattle that yeah he's over it
it's y'all good poodle and then and and
and they they keep it so timely that
there's Nick nurse in the middle of the
episode at one point just going doing
the mean yeah those guys are brilliant
two brilliant
yeah I don't want to give them too much
compliments alright no idear okay have
you had them on this no you Chi had him
on a radio show back in the day their
Eagles fans so I should have them on I
don't care what kind of fans they are
they should be on because they do great
because they're hyping among Asian
geniuses yeah I don't know I got to see
them a lot I don't really glad you don't
see me that much alright never been on
the show - it'll change after a while
those better enjoy my only appearance
when when you guys make magic which is
what I think you guys do a lot
have you felt like other networks or
anything has ever tried to steal it or
tried to replicate it do you think
people come by and they like look around
and they're trying to find the secret
sauce no I what I think is and I think
it was fairly obvious after a couple of
years of Chuck being on our show is that
is that you know and I'm not specifying
network's nose or anything like that but
shows were like we need a Charles
Barkley on
I mean that's what you need somebody
little tiny need somebody who's gonna be
a little outlandish a little outrageous
going to say but they don't realize or
maybe they did realize but Chuck had
built that equity up over the years
Chuck had gone through you know whatever
how many years he played in the NBA 15
years or something as the most quotable
guy out there it didn't matter what the
topic was
if you needed a quote you went to
Charles if you recover in the NBA so he
so he jumps into our set with that kind
of a resume and people expected that
yeah and so you couldn't just hire
somebody who's a former player who's not
you know it doesn't have the cachet that
Chuck has and say okay you're here I'm
going to show you this tape be that guy
but I think there I think there were
shows that we're trying to shoe it and
saying oh yeah you need to you know but
there's only one Charles there really I
mean and thankfully he's on our team and
the other thing is too is hope you'll
think he's watching the news and then
he'll go awful bounce Paris and you're
like how did you see that and what but
that's all of them to like I'll watch
Kenny like I'll sit in that room oh you
watch games where in your office yeah so
and then they all watch together and
then like Chicago and DJ for a quarter
and all that guys are kind of spread out
it's not like we're all sitting in these
room and just watching the game and
saying hey that was good let's talk
about that okay yeah because I've got a
lot of like especially on regular season
games I'll have two monitors on in my
yeah in my office and I'm trying to keep
a little bit of a of a game log yes like
scoring runs big plays injuries this guy
left you know this guy got two fouls and
went out for this much of time so I'm
I'm doing that and I can't do that
you know in the other one at all because
there's too much it's you know right in
the middle of something Charles to say
can you believe they acquitted that guy
and then you got 15 people all yelling
that's the thing and I'm trying to hear
you know cuz I want to hear the game -
because if Marv or like Chris Webber
says something and it's saying like well
I can't wait to hear what Charles has to
say at the
laugh about that I gotta hear that you
know what reduced it all back yeah
so when you talk to them coming out of
halftime juice it's it's impossible in
that setting because there's too much
other stuff being discussed it's awesome
yeah it is I mean it's a great place if
you're like if you were in love to sit
in that room and watch a half a bass
people will always go where do you like
to watch the big game some people I like
to watch it at home oh I like to watch
it at a bar I was like look I've
experienced the coolest place to watch a
game yeah it's inside the NBA in that
room where Charles and Kenny and Shaq
are putting on a show for it like
everyone that's in the room yeah but as
soon as that basketball gets tight they
it's and there and they pick up on
things that I don't even notice and I
think that's the really the brilliance
of Chuck sometimes too is whole say
things so matter of fact that they you
know just go Kyle Lowry can't have zero
points and and I didn't even realize
that you know because in the flow of the
game sometimes those things get that put
under the rug and to me it's it's Kenny
too because absolutely when Kenny does
his run to the wall break oh yeah you
know in the best description I can give
you is the producer will always tell me
as we're getting ready for half we're in
that commercial break break before
halftime starts and so I said what kind
of what a Shaq got yeah they'll say he's
doing a breakdown on yoga okay good
what's Kenny got well he's got some
plays but I don't know exactly what they
are but Kenny knows what they are yes
and ice and then I'll just I said give
me something broad strokes well how can
I get it to you
dribbling you know no dribble or he says
you know valuing possessions okay you
know so I know that's they're gonna be
the theme of a seal and it's gonna have
both teams and it's gonna have maybe the
somebody hitting two three somebody
turning the ball over and and so he sees
it in a different way and then there are
other times he comes out and I said what
you got and he said I had something but
now I don't have anything because
something happened in the game that made
those that made it a moot point okay
that's fine he will literally turn
around to a producer and go two minutes
in they had that one break and then four
after that they had the three and I'm
sitting there going how did you remember
all that yeah yeah but that's that's why
everyone can think it's a joke and it's
all right no there's so many little
piece and then I don't know how you guys
all make it to set on time like I feel
like you're all over the world and then
I turn on the TV and it's like
everybody's there and you're all dressed
well most of the time
Kenny missed a show once what he missed
a pregame show but he brave he blamed a
zebra that got loose on the expressway
because the zebra once did get loose on
the expressway he was that I think what
his hotel was nowhere near where the
zebra was but he used it and if he'd not
hear the end of that for weeks
years we still bring it up really yeah
you know if he just if he cuts it close
hey he just Zeeland ate it was there a
zebra yeah
favorite moment that you've that
instantly makes you start laughing
inside when you rethink about it Kenny
when I ran Kenny over with a car Coby
reenactment commercial yeah because the
call Kenny thought it was gonna be was
him reenacting the Kobe commercial he
left it to the production crew to have
you finish it up I did my jump you guys
will do all the special effects yeah and
then I was like you know we should have
they said what we want to do is have
maybe the car hit Kenny and he would so
it'll be unexpected I said well that's
great I said I should be driving the car
yeah so then we shot all this stuff and
then when it hit when it hit the air and
Kobe was live with us after watching it
in noise that's Muskoka I haven't seen
any of that we haven't seen this yet you
haven't seen it we're all gonna watch it
together and then what they put together
was just did you just watch Kenny the
whole time
Tori when that was airing yeah I miss
guy was like he thinks it's gonna be
it's gonna look just like the Aston
Martin going under going under Coby but
now it was like bang he gets flattened
but that's that's the thing you know we
had to send we had to send a PA or a
runner we had to send to the adult
novelty store to buy holo up though
that's amazing because we needed
something to hit and you know here's
life of us he ain't kids saying man I've
made it big I'm working for inside the
NBA and I had to go
the adult store I just think about him
telling this mom what you do for work
today it's a long story dad the guys
than the guys like well you know how
much you want to spend cuz we got like
three or four different kinds and he's
like the cheapest I got I got two more
for you cuz I know you're a busy guy you
gotta go oh come on man we can go on for
a long time don't tempt me Ernie I will
keep you here forever look
what is one debate or discussion that
you'd like to retire that you're tired
of people coming up to you and asking
you're tired of people debating on the
Internet
what is one sports debate discussion
you're done with I don't know you know
what I I just you tire a little bit Adam
of of everybody looking at every day
that happens in sports like there has to
be some defining you know that's this
game was great what was it the greatest
game ever played was this the blueprint
on how to beat there was this was this
the blueprint does this game validate
that he's the greatest of all time or is
this you know is this the great why do
we have to categorize everything anytime
anything happens as being the best or
being not not hey now he's one of the
five greatest isn't he no that's all fun
water cooler stuff anybody actually has
a water cooler anymore
but it's is that an age thing do young
people do that because they they don't
value like longevity and with yeah it's
I mean it's a microwave Society these
days that everything's has to be you
know I want to see it I'm you know I'd
like to watch a game but I want it to
take thirty minutes I don't want to sit
through the whole thing right and I want
you know I want answers I want to know
if the thing I just saw is actually the
greatest of all time so link I think a
lot of the goat I think a lot of the
goat debates or number one go I was
tired yeah yeah when you when Bill
Buckner was the goat he was the gun he
was the goat and
and you nobody wanted to be the goat and
now it's like you know you see a little
you see a little goat emoji on a thing
and it's like wow thank you and that
what that emoji will spark in 2000
comment debates yeah exactly
but but yeah I think I think I just tire
a little bit of trying to decide who was
the best of all time and who was because
there's no way we can do as the best of
them you know what you know what best
player ever at best NBA player I ever
watched was Michael Jordan and that's I
mean that's just that's just it
my favorite player growing up with speed
Maravich oh you know he he was the guy
24 LS he he was a guy I mean I saw him
my dad took me to watch Georgia play LSU
and Athens
yeah when Pete was when Pete was a
towaway I grew up watching Pete Maravich
VHS tapes that my dad made me watch yeah
I mean all that stuff all the dribbling
things and I was like you want me to
learn how to do that like he just went
like this and it went that way oh and
here's the deal like I'm playing you
know I'm playing basketball back in
those days and everybody was wearing
floppy socks and trying to grow their
hair a little longer so it would bounce
on their head when they was like the
Beatles you know he had that everybody
wanted to be Pete but it was never like
when I watched Pete I said I want to do
that it was like wow I'll never be able
to ever ever it didn't drive me ya have
better handles and throw no-look passes
it was just like well that guy's not
another planet I'll never do that Pistol
Pete was incredible and then my other
question was like Shaq comes in and you
Kenny and Charles have been together for
how long at that point I mean that was
mercy twelve I think I see I guess it
was the it was the strike-shortened or
the lockout-shortened season so 11 12
like seven eight years yeah and you were
together for about 12 years and yeah so
what's your question what that
transition process yeah you're you're
kind of the shepherd I feel like where
you're gonna be the voice of reason and
you're gonna you're gonna hear it from
everywhere the executives are gonna come
to you and go how's this going your
co-hosts are gonna come to you and go
what do you think was it easy from the
beginning was it was it tumultuous at
first cuz
right now is beautiful well how did you
navigate that it was I mean there was an
adjustment period for sure
but I think what attracted shaq to our
show was the fun that we have and look
players watched the show he did they
know what we do they know what's said
about certain players and if they don't
hear it then their fellows have heard
and it's like you hear what Charles
Barkley said about you hear what Kenny
said and and in addition was all the fun
stuff you know was all the you know
doing the champions Club and keeping
Charles out of a halftime show cuz he
does never rent and here's a diaper
changing contest verse charles trying to
set the record for holding its breath
underwater you know the night that david
blaine was on so they see all that stuff
and then want to be part of it and shack
is the world's biggest kid home so
immediately I mean first show he's it's
a Christmas show and he's if you push
that Christmas tree over on me it'll
give him getting like a million YouTube
hits you know okay so we'll do it he had
a little gag and where he was shooting
the jumper and somebody pushed a
Christmas tree over on him and he fell
down but then it was like he wanted
every show to have some moment like that
that we got to the point where Charles
and Kenny and I were joke as a check you
don't need to think of something every
you know the brain in turn every charge
you're gonna want it you're gonna want
to be set on fire if you keep this up he
says I've been to so I've been to Stone
school you could do that and it's like
don't we don't want to and so I think
again a lot of the funniest stuff on the
show just happens organically and
unexpectedly and not just you know not
setting it up but you know shacking now
be honest a Shack and I had a couple of
conversations mmm-hmm and you know when
he got to work and I hate come to my
office for a second and I said look
you're doing great and I know you're
having a good time yeah we've had some
stuff I said but I said as much
outrageous stuff as Charles might say
and as crazy as the show might get from
time to time he always comes in with at
least a handful of things he wants to
get off his chest some time during the
night in the course of that doubleheader
he's got
he wants to talk about the Laker
situation he wants to talk about a trade
he's heard of he wants to talk about
some friction between two players
there's something going on in the league
he wants to talk about and so I said do
yourself a favor and come into each show
armed that way yeah
here's here a few things I want to talk
about and and I think it really
benefited him and and look and look Shaq
is he he wants to excel at anything he
does it's it's evident and I think one
of the biggest problems we have in our
business is we hire people who are
athletes and put them on TV and say hope
it works
mmm and don't get many feedback mmm none
nobody goes through misses you really
need to work on this you know look you
don't the way you express this you need
to do it this way or you need to be a
little shorter if you're if you're gonna
be doing analysis you know of a game you
need to be a little more concise ya need
to give your play-by-play guy they
nobody gets that nobody gets that kind
of feedback it's just like they'll do
something and they'll keep on doing it
and it's like yeah and so when I saw
Shaq it was like I'm gonna let me help
you out mmm you know I love what you do
I love your personality I'm lucky to
work with you yeah but here's how you
can be even better is you come in and
have a few things you really want to
talk about and and he's fit right in I
mean we've come on man I know you know
when television of course how how often
does it last that long before somebody
wants to wants to put their input in
there wants to say well I'm the new
executive producer and I think you
should be doing this and you should be
doing this and I want to break this up
sometimes sometimes you just gotta let
it go and say guys just you know keep it
up you know that's why when I see EJ's
nito's stat of the night brought to you
by no one and unsullied by sponsorship
since 1989 1989 it has been sponsored
everything of course of course for the
most part it's the one thing our are
saying we have the greatest sales people
in the world they'll sell any
thing I mean and they'll sell a timeout
or this breath taken by this coach is
sponsored by you know and here we go to
the neato stat of the night which often
times is hilarious and it's like no
nipples out there no but nobody wants to
sponsor this so now it's a badge of
honor but that's that to me though is
you're showing the seams they're
breaking down the fourth wall and you're
showing in that little clip can take the
edge off the seriousness of the entire
show yeah because you go we can left
ourselves
oh that's been you know that's been the
whole key to to having the show work is
that nobody's ever tried to make the
show about them and even though you have
personalities who could do that and if
someone does you guys jump down their
throat oh so quick no you're exactly
right yeah you're exactly right and so
you self monitor yeah and and and
everybody kind of while we don't
necessarily stay in our lanes we know
our roles and so I'm never gonna try to
be the one who who you know dominates
the conversation about what's being said
in the huddle with 1.3 seconds left I've
never been there these guys have you
know I'm there the players
I'm the TV guy who's trying to get us
from point A to point B to Point C and
spark some conversation and you know
keep this guy from killing this guy and
laughing this off and trying to play
that off and and it works and nobody's
ever
and nobody's ever said don't say that
about me that's yeah you know and that's
something you see in TV too a lot is you
know you take somebody who's
high-profile and it's like and we would
like to make fun of you tonight with
this and it's like no you can't do that
meantime we wait on the air when he when
he starts working for us because he's
about 700 pounds
building out the sides of the set and
and he's vowing to to get down to his
playing weight and so weird we're
waiting we're taking a scale were
weighing him periodically during the
season and and he's fine with it
yeah and we just laugh at it how much
were you making it Macon Georgia when
you're a local guy
are you kidding I was in my first market
was Hastings and I made 18 five I'm just
in what year was a 2000 and was he says
we're going back to 1970 bet you a 1979
this is gonna show you how bad inflation
on car industry Macon Georgia news
anchor at the age of 23 yeah $10,000
$10,000 to anchor the news could like I
look back in mines 11 years and yours is
40 years could you not could you do it
all again but like you remember that
Ernie Wright okay could you even explain
to that Ernie what happens after that no
right no it just feels like fortuitous
bounces and luck you knows because at
that point all you're trying to do okay
you've gotten that first TV job which is
huge because now I'm gonna this is what
I people think you may because you're on
cap oh my god but do you dude it's like
okay now are you good enough to go to
the next mark it's only you're in the
35th mark I mean I'm in the hundred and
thirty fifth TV market out of two
hundred and twenty you know and it's
like okay we're we're grinding and
there's something work rind in there's
no teleprompter it's you know I'm
reading the news like this it's like the
bobblehead and and you're scared to
death every stolen life cuz thank you
because you feel like if you stumble
over anything and and it was like hey
Wilma come over here and watch this
youngster trying to read the news he's
he's struggling you got like three ties
oh yeah a blue blazer yeah that's all
you these eyes yeah and and trying to
maybe put your own makeup on you have no
idea what you look like and look like a
Caribbean cruise and put bronzer
everywhere exactly yeah and you know
very white neck at an orange face and so
and you're using your like using words
that you'd never use yeah no
conversation yeah yeah of course
and then you go
after a while and you say okay I'd
really like to move up I'd like to make
more money I'd like to go to a place
that has better equipment I'd like you
know you know want to move up the ladder
yeah and so then they in Spartanburg
South Carolina they're hiring a general
assignment reporter you know again this
is I'm I'm all doing news at this point
same that's what I did and I couldn't
get into sports yeah so a year and a
half in Macon and then a year and then I
go to Spartanburg for a year and that's
the 35th market so I go from 135 to 35
how long the join and it's like whoa
this is this is great you got an entire
four that my two things for you yes you
got a guy who's not with one man you
know you still had two one-man band some
yeah but you're you're you're working
with people who have been in the
business for longer and and a lot of
guys your age you were on that same kind
of path and it's everybody's like out
working everybody else you're and
anytime they need anybody to do anything
it's me oh yeah I would love to anchor
Christmas yeah well yeah sure I'll do
I'll you know I'll do whatever you know
I'll get up in the middle of the night
shoot a fire took a camera home and so
so I do that for a year and then I'm
trying to you know this is the
ridiculous thing is that in 1982 I've
been there for a year I had signed a
two-year deal and the news director had
told me if if you get a chance to go to
a big market I'll let you go I'm not
gonna stand in your way for that and and
so I start throwing out a couple of
tapes Atlanta's way and and at the same
time I Cheryl and I are gonna get
married we decide we're gonna get
married and and I was like yeah let's
get married in August this is like in
February March we're talking I said
let's get married in August I'll have a
job in Atlanta by then and and like when
I told that to my dad he was like do you
hear yourself you just think you're
gonna get a job in Atlanta I mean don't
you think maybe you should wait until
that happens and then you guys can I
said dad
I'm gonna get a job in Atlanta and I go
to channel 5 and they're not hiring and
I send a tapes to and I get interviewed
at WSB channel too and I go back to
Spartanburg and then two weeks later the
phone rings and they say when can you
start
mmm like how about that I said here it
is it's it's March of 82 we're gonna be
married in August and I'm gonna have a
job at the WS until the folks in
Spartanburg said hey you got a two-year
contract what are you talking about and
the GM called me up to his office's what
do you think you're doing the same GM
know this is the news director until o
GM unbeknownst to the GM GM said what
are you doing I said what do you mean
what am i doing he said I said aren't
you gonna like say congratulations on
the you're gettin ya plant a job he said
all right you got a contract they said
you know it's come on man this is
Atlanta yeah I said you got a contract
and I said news director told me he
would never stand in my way
he says I've talked in the news director
he said he didn't mention that I'm bound
to the news directors office no I think
you need to have a conversation with the
GM yeah and then that conversation took
place and GM called me back up and he
said good luck in Atlanta I said I
understand but the situation but that
was kind of that very similar thing
happen to me in Louisville yeah well the
bleacher report you're thinking oh wow
here's the brake and then it's like what
oh yeah you see your whole life out of
you yeah could you imagine how if you
had to stay in spark no offense to
Spartanburg but like how much your life
would have changed yeah it would have
been if would have been oh really
I don't I don't know if Cheryl Ann would
have moved up there what is that
yeah your dad's right let's wait until
that Atlanta thing happens before but
but really and not really nothing
against of course no not against any
places you're learning because every
place you work you learn something that
is of immense value down the line and so
for every stop I've ever made from doing
radio to go in to make and to go to
Spartanburg
- those two working weekends doing
sports in Atlanta all that stuff all
adds up to make you podcaster that you
are in very rare you never forget some
of those moments that happened never and
say yeah I think we just when you think
you've seen it all and something will
happen every now and then that you
haven't seen haven't experienced this
before and I appreciate you Ernie or the
men if you're down we can do this again
oh yeah now I have Chris and Charles as
my sports uncle I don't know what title
for you yet if you'd like to brainstorm
that you're his he's my son's all sports
uncle yeah Oh Bart Scott is my football
older brother hmm well since I'm really
I'll be your sports grandfather merci
I'm actually a grandfather and I got
four grand I didn't want to say that
term because I didn't want to do like an
age thing home so you'll be my sports
grandfather your sports grandfather
that's incredible yeah that would be
that would be an honor you're amazing
Charles amazing six kids six kids
uniform and kids yeah Ernie living it up
I mean you know what what a good spot
man yeah I'm in a good spot all right
homies you guys are amazing as always
hit up Ernie on social - what is your
turn or sports DJ and just Brett like a
barrage of compliments like so much that
it makes them sick yeah that's what I
want just a series of goat emojis would
be great just goods demanded thanks
thank you
[Music]